well yes i was very euphoric i was very
relieved it was a really really great
moment you know it was one of those uh
you know fist air punching moments
really really happy
but unfortunately the atmosphere has
been a bit flat since then uh as your
no no no it hasn't been plain sailing uh
you know i can hear the cheers from from
your recording it was absolutely
fantastic at that time um
and then we started to get some data
back uh so from the ptolemy mission
we've had data which is just absolutely
wonderful
but
the press conference when we were
expecting some images it didn't happen
it was postponed there's obviously some
problems um which we've heard about
so we're now just waiting we've got to
wait until tomorrow to find out exactly
what's happened and of course the clock
is ticking isn't it because filet's got
a limited battery life initially hasn't
it how much of a risk is this
that's right
well that's right i mean it has its its
batteries there which are only
programmed or only have enough power for
a very relatively short period of time
and we've got to hope that the solar
panels will kick in the problem is that
we have had radio contact and a lot of
radio contact between the rosetta
mothership and feli um and so it landed
it settled but it looks as if the actual
drill screws didn't take and that it's
just sitting there it's not actually
anchored and that meant that it seemed
to rise again and we assume
from the radio signal that it's fallen
again and it's actually on the surface
but rosetta sorry the comet has now
tumbled a little bit it's turned in its
orbit and rosetta is over the horizon or
below the horizon rather so rosetta
cannot get the radio link to the um to
feli and won't for another few more
hours so we're not going to know for a
few more hours whether that radio link
can be established again so it's it's
been tense then it was fantastic and now
it's gone tense again
so after initial inferiority thought
we've achieved the impossible perhaps
now it isn't what we hoped for then
well we've had some we've had some great
pictures um we've got some wonderful
data on plasma we've got some amazing
data we believe coming from the ptolemy
instrument
we've heard that we've got data down but
we haven't started interpreting it yet
so we know there has been some
incredible data already we're just
hoping that there's going to be some
more
this of course has been a pan european
effort how well has that team work
together it is extraordinary the efforts
have been put in
well the european space agency of course
coordinates the actions of all the space
agencies of european nations plus canada
um
for some strange reason um and the
teams are funded partly by esa and
partly by their national agencies so the
lander is funded by the uk space agency
it's funded by the german space agency
italian french and so on so there's a
lot of international effort gone into it
and one of the marvelous things with the
lander is the cooperation and
collaboration that has taken place among
the principal investigations of the
instruments because you've got sort of
the power of a light bulb which has got
to power six different instruments and
they can't all have it switched on at
the same time so there has to be this
cooperation to make sure things work
well and so far for the lander it has
been working very well indeed